auch hier im studio wollen wir weiter
über dieses thema sprechen über dieses
man kann es nicht anders sagen zynische
machtspiel bei uns hier im studio partie
merck cdu generalsekretär und auch bild
live chef claus strunz es hier guten
morgen herr sie mag die situation wenn
wir in diesen zaun schauen wenn wir die
bilder auch als der nacht sehen wohin
sollen die menschen wohin sollen die
tausenden menschen die dort stehen zu
dieser welt leben wir wirklich über die
kriegsführung dass es menschenverachtend
was dort passiert und wir müssen jetzt
ein noch härteres vorgehen gegen
lukaschenko und alle veranlassen die
daran beteiligt sind und das ist nicht
nur das regime in minsk sondern alle die
daran beteiligt sind heißt also auch die
fluglinien und die herkunftsländer denn
ehrlicherweise sie wissen was sie tun
niemand wirklich heißt jetzt mit seiner
familie zu herrn lukaschenko um dort
urlaub zu machen mit einem
touristenvisum sondern die menschen
sollen dann an die grenze gebracht
werden dass es menschen verachten und
deswegen brauchen wir ein hartes
vorgehen auch gegen die fluglinie und
die europäische union muss stark genug
sein dort vorzugehen und andere seiten
aufzuziehen aber sie sehen bisher ist zu
wenig passiert aber was konkret jetzt
haben wir ja menschen die dort die
nächte frieren die dort ausharren
tausende die heute auto über die grenze
gekommen sind wir wollen ihnen einen
menschen ganz im besonderen einmal von
den 14 jährigen jungen
wie so viele andere auch wie so viele
andere sala kommen nein ganz
ausdrücklich nein denn wir dürfen jetzt
kein zeichen senden dass die menschen
weiter reisen können nach deutschland
das ist doch das worum es geht die mit
den menschen wird versprochen ihr kommt
in die europäische union und machen wir
uns nichts vor die menschen wollen doch
jetzt nicht in polen bleiben sondern sie
wollen weiter reisen und deswegen müssen
wir folgende dinge tun wir müssen als
erstes den polen unterstützung und
solidarität zukommen lassen erster sie
unterstützen auch in der sicherung der
grenze wenn sie es brauchen praktisch
aber auch politisch den polen beschützt
die außengrenzen der europäischen union
und mit zerstörung dieser grenze ist
nicht hinzunehmen und wenn menschen sich
an den grenzübergangs punkten melden und
asyl beantragen dann müssen sie
aufgenommen werden dann bekommen sie ein
verfahren und dann müssen sie auch
menschenwürdig untergebracht werden aber
das mussten nicht zwangsläufig
in der europäischen union sein sondern
man kann auch mit anderen ländern
sprechen wie zum beispiel der ukraine um
menschen auch dort unterzubringen denn
wir müssen das zeichen setzen wir halten
uns an die regeln die wir uns selbst
gesetzt haben wir behandeln menschen
menschenwürdig aber das ist nicht
gleichzusetzen mit jeder kann kommen und
jeder kann in der eu blasi sagen diesem
14-jährigen redest ahmad ins gesicht an
dieser stelle nein er sollen nicht kommt
das ist rechtlich völlig in ordnung das
ist auch eine ganz klare aussage die
frage ist wie lange sie das durchhalten
können so klar hat sie im übrigen kaum
jemand gesagt in den vergangenen tagen
wie lange sie das durchhalten wenn sich
das drama zuspitzt an diesem zaun den
wir gesehen haben die menschen frieren
die brauchen decken in der nacht
lukaschenko erpresst uns gerade das
heißt wir schauen zu wie es den menschen
tag für tag schlechter geht wie
möglicherweise das sterben an diesem
zaun beginnt schauen sie weiter zu sagen
sie tage lang nein halten sie das durch
so sehen sie und jetzt sind wir wieder
in einer debatte wo wir dinge
miteinander vermischen ich sage wir
dürfen jetzt kein zeichen senden dass
jeder nach deutschland kommen kann und
sie sagen jetzt sterben genau das ist
der unterschied ich sage es soll keiner
sterben und wir müssen menschen
humanitär versorgen wir müssen sie auch
aufnehmen aber das muss nicht in der
europäischen union sein denn sie müssen
immer die folge frage beantworten wenn
sie heute sagen diese gruppe darf in die
bundesrepublik kommen welchen grund
haben die menschen morgen nicht sich von
lukaschenko missbrauchen zu lassen und
wieder an die grenze zu kommen sie
wollen heute ja sagen um morgen nein zu
sagen das macht vailati wenig findet sie
gar nicht abbringen von ihrer haltung
ich will nur wissen wie lange wir es
durchhalten denn die drohung aus - die
sind ja brutal wir schauen und hören
noch einmal rein in die aktuellste
drohung von belarus diktator lukaschenko
auch
wenn wir gott bewahre einen fehler
machen oder einen falschen schritt tun
dann wird das sofort russland auf den
plan rufen eine nukleare supermacht ich
bin nicht verrückt ich kann mir nur zu
gut vorstellen was sich daraus
entwickeln kann die abwahl von
motorradpolizisten
das klingt muss man sagen nach einer
sehr konkreten drohungen hatte sieht er
muss ja mittlerweile selbst betonen dass
er nicht verrückt ist das was er macht
ist mit allerletzten macht sich zu
wehren und außenpolitische ziele zu
verfolgen
und natürlich spielt moskau eine große
rolle in diesem menschenverachtenden
spiel und deswegen dürfen wir gerade
nicht nachgeben denn mit jedem tag indem
wir sagen nein wir halten es nicht aus
unsere grenze zu sichern und auf ordnung
zu bringen und ordnung heißt wer sich
registrieren lassen will der geht an
einer regulären
grenzübergangs punkt und meldet sich und
bekommt dann ein verfahren aber wir
müssen auch die frage beantworten was
passiert mit den menschen die keinen
anspruch auf asyl haben und seien wir
doch ehrlich miteinander wenn menschen
sich entscheiden nicht zu dem polnischen
grenzbeamten zu gehen an einem
grenzübergangs punkt sondern an die
grüne grenze vorbei an diesem
grenzübergangs punkte offen germany
germany wohin wollen die menschen sie
wollen in die bundesrepublik deutschland
und sie wollten sich nicht registrieren
lassen zumindest ein großteil von ihnen
nicht jetzt hält sie hier das ist alles
in allen ehren und klar ausgedrückt aber
die kanzlerin noch kanzlerin
geschäftsführende kanzlerin angesichts
dieser bilder und in einem sozusagen
rückblick auf ihre amtszeit festgestellt
wir haben das geschafft also wir haben
die integration geschafft wir haben
eine migrationspolitik entwickelt die
stand hält diese bilder dementieren
durch die ehemalige bundeskanzlerin oder
sehen sie das anders haben wir es
geschafft ich sehe ist anders ich würde
andere worte wählen und das tue ich
jetzt auch so wenn man sieht was für
herausforderungen wir hatten in den
letzten jahren wenn sie sich die
migrationsbewegung und alleine die
zahlen anschauen von 2015 und die
entwicklung in den kommenden jahren dann
haben wir sehr viel erreicht und
deswegen können wir auf das was erreicht
wurde
zurückblicken aber mit mit einem iran
gegenteil also wir haben wir stehen
hilflos
fassungslos und wieder mit dem blick auf
die moody's irgend nachrichten muss vor
diesen bildern die situation einer
galanten die ersten also kommen weitere
flieger noch mehr menschen noch mehr das
ist ein gezielter angriff auf unser
wertesystem das ist nutzt unseren
wichtigen humanistischen gedanken aus
und wir stehen da und sagen ja also da
muss jetzt irgendwie die fluglinien
kontrolliert werden das wird ein
bisschen hilflos dass ich nicht also wir
versuchen jetzt das alles mit angela
merkel in verbindung zu bringen aber die
noch einmal nach mit langen kanzlerin
2014 hat sie handy videos und macht das
die so interpretiert werden dass leute
nach deutschland kommen sollen jetzt
sind wir noch in einer völlig anderen
situation
ursächlich für diese situation ist
lukaschenko lukaschenko lässt die leute
nicht nur kommen sondern er will gerade
dass sie kommen schickt sie dann an die
grenze lässt sich von seinen truppen die
uniformiert sind ohne hoheitszeichen
pusht die richtig gegen die polnische
grenze an der grünen grenze und lässt
jetzt übrigens in diesem wald bei diesen
temperaturen aus haben aber ich stelle
nur fest sie sind andere meinungen als
angela merkel wir haben es nicht
geschafft wir haben ein teil des weges
hinter uns aber wir haben es nicht
geschafft was heißt was heißt geschlafen
ja jetzt nicht meine warten schade ich
schaue auf die situation wie sie 2015
war und ich schaue auf das was erreicht
wurde und das ziemlich viel wir haben
ziemlich viel erreicht und die situation
ist heute eine völlig andere als noch
vor allen dingen frage ist halt nur kann
man überhaupt in diesen tagen wenn uns
solche bilder erreichen kann man
überhaupt auf die idee kommen den satz
zu sagen ja wir haben es geschafft das
wirkt einfach absurd hat sie mir wir
werden in den nächsten jahren in der
frage der migration immer wieder auf mit
solchen bildern ist zu tun haben zu
glauben dass das ein abgeschlossenes
kapitel ist das ist eines der großen
zukunftsthemen wie menschen sich bewegen
wo sie leben wollen wir haben mehrere
globale themen den klimaschutz aber eben
auch die migration und deswegen sage ich
ihnen das ist nicht das letzte mal dass
wir über diese fragen sprechen ist muss
denn die ampel tun jetzt ganz konkret
was muss herr scholz tun was ist ihre
forderungen
ich habe jetzt gerade gesagt was zu tun
ist und das steht für sich wir müssen
dem polen solidarität erklären und nicht
bei kalender sprüchen bleiben also diese
frage ja wir müssen jetzt
die menschen aufnehmen das geht ja
einige die das fordern bei spd und
grünen die jetzt noch leistungen für
asylbewerber erhöhen wollen die ein
sogenanntes moderne
staatsbürgerschaftsrecht mehr einführen
wollen wo es einfacher gelingt die
deutschen pass zu haben beantwortet
keine der fragen wie wir heute und vor
allem morgen mit dieser situation
umgehen ist solidarität mit polen sind
zentrale stichwort wenn die polen uns
bitten würden bundeswehr oder
bundesgrenzschutz einheiten zu schicken
sollen wir müssen wir schicken aus
diesem solidaritätsgedanken heraus gibt
es ja gar keine andere wahl wenn die
polen das anfordern über die europäische
union dann muss deutschland bereit seien
natürlich auch zu helfen
selbstverständlich auch warum nicht auch
mit bundeswehr und grenzschutz wenn die
polen sagen sie brauchen unterstützung
in diesem oder jenem bereich dann wollen
wir das prüfen und wir sollten uns dafür
entscheiden weil wir nachbarn sind und
es ist unsere gemeinsame grenze wir
sollten nicht so tun als ob das in der
polnischen grenze ist es die außengrenze
der nato zu lukaschenko es ist die
europäische außengrenze also die grenze
der europäischen union als claus strunz
karte von einem angriff gesprochen hat
haben sie gesagt ja das ist es das ist
ein angriff bedeute dass man für
lukaschenko kann das sein dass der
bündnisfall notwendig wird donald tusk
sagt genau dass das ist nicht
irgendjemand der ersten moment
opposition in polen aber war eben
eu-ratspräsident wie sie wissen ja
spricht schon von den bündnisfall kann
es ein bündnisfall werden also über
diese ebene hierzu diskutieren halte ich
für nicht richtig sondern wir müssen
jetzt alles dafür tun um mit zu
deeskalieren und lukaschenko muss
einfach merken er kommt mit dieser
menschenverachtenden taktik nicht weiter
das heißt nicht immer mehr menschen
werden dort an die grenze kommen sondern
sie werden sehen es gibt keine chance
über weißrussland in die europäische
union zu gelangen und alle die sich
daran beteiligt haben und beteiligen
werden werden es hart spüren die
europäische union hat natürlich die
macht auf fluglinien auf herkunftsländer
einzuwirken wenn sie denn will aber die
chance geht es heute nach gab es die
loch im grenzzaun die chance jetzt sind
die menschen in der europäischen union
sehen wollen die chance ist ja jetzt da
wir sehen jetzt dass die polnischen
sicherheitsbehörden die polizei die vor
ort ist aber auch die streitkräfte das
versuchen zu unterbinden und so fort
wenn die mensch dem versuchen diesen
grenzzaun zu zerstören sie trotzdem
keine möglichkeit haben gegen das
polnische staatsgebiet einzudringen und
das ist übrigens auch kein regulärer
grenzübertritt wenn man eine grenzanlage
zerstört und sich mit gewalt zugang zu
einem land verschafft noch eine
persönliche frage hat sie mir sie kennen
polen richtig guten ja dort aufgewachsen
ich glaube bis zum 13 lebensjahr wenn
ich richtig bis zum dritten aber ich
kenne es immer wieder falsch gerechnet
aber die ersten jahre haben sie dort
verbracht haben nach wie vor enge
beziehungen dorthin kennen
möglicherweise auch das grenzgebiet oder
gebiete wie diese ich stelle mir das
schrecklich vor auch für die soldaten
für die grenzpolizisten die dort im
einsatz sind natürlich ist das deren job
aber sie schauen den menschen in die
augen sehen das leid auf der anderen
seite und sie müssen das abwehren sie
müssen diesen menschen entgegen treten
sie stehen konkret vor dieser situation
die menschen nicht reinlassen zu dürfen
die aber nichts anderes wollen als das
was können sie diesen grenzpolizisten
diesen polnischen grenzpolizisten und
soldaten ganz persönlich sagen
vielleicht sogar in deren sprache ja das
will ich jetzt nicht tun wir wollen das
auch nicht zu sehr auf eine emotionale
ebene heben sondern ich sage einfach
danke für ihren dienst den sie leisten
denn die alle polnischen kräfte die dort
an der grenze sind müssen wissen sie
tuns nicht nur für polen sondern sie tun
es für alle mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union jetzt haben wir eben
gerade gehört was lukas schenkel gesagt
hatte und auch hinter ihnen sehen wir
ihn zusammensitzen mit putin mit der
großen frage sind wir auf diesen krieg
vorbereitet haben sie das was du
geschenke da gesagt hat als kriegs
drohung empfunden und wenn ja wären wir
auf diesen krieg vorbereitet es ist ja
eine neue art von der kriegsführung es
ist eine hybride kriegsführung es ist
eine kriegsführung über bilder über die
frage wie lange hält die europäische
union auch diese widersprüchlichkeit aus
nämlich die frage von humanität und
ordnung man braucht beides man kann sich
nicht nur man kann nicht nur ein aspekt
beurteilen und ich finde es geht gar
nicht nur um die frage der vorbereitung
sondern die frage haben wir den willen
das gemeinsam zu bestehen diese diese
probe auch geopolitische probe die
moskau und minsk auf uns zu gucken wen
aber auch die schnelligkeit und die
bereitschaft schnell zur hand und wenn
wir da jetzt ganz gern mal in die eu
geschichte so zurückblicken dann war das
nicht unbedingt immer da wir kommen
jetzt aus der krise wo die impfungen
nicht funktioniert man hat ein angebot
an das ganze noch verlangsamt haben
haben sie den eindruck ursula von der
leyen und die eu die sind da jetzt
wirklich dahinter da passiert was jetzt
in den nächsten tagen wie diese bilder
sehen ja den eindruck habe ich weil
jeder die situation sieht aber wir haben
ganz unterschiedliche
vorstellungen davon auch für
migrationspolitik aussieht machen wir
uns doch nichts vor es gibt einige
wenige die sagen nein es soll möglich
sein in die europäische union zu kommen
und wir verteilen die menschen
verpflichtend auf die einzelnen staaten
eine mehrheit will das nicht in dieser
frage und deswegen das ist das problem
dass es unterschiedliche vorstellungen
gibt weniger die frage der
geschwindigkeit sondern die
geschwindigkeit oder die fehlende
einigung in manchen themen hat auch was
mit politischem willen zu tun jetzt gibt
es mehrere gruppen eine seebrücke
machten besonders schlagzeilen menschen
die sich vorgenommen haben die
flüchtlinge in sicherheit zu bringen die
mit bussen dahin fahren die dabei
gesetze übertreten was sind das für sie
träumer menschen mit dem herz am rechten
fleck
kriminelle also ich finde jeder der sich
einsetzt dafür dass menschen ein
besseres leben haben und nicht erfrieren
der hatte auf jeden fall das herz am
rechten knie das herz am richtigen fleck
das sage ich absolut nur eine aufgabe
ist von politik nicht nur die einzelne
person zu sehen die dort an der grenze
ist sondern ich muss auch die frage
beantworten wie es unsere antwort für
die kinder lieben morgen an dieser
grenze stehen werden und übermorgen und
die antwort kann eben aus unserer sicht
nicht sein jeder kann den die
bundesrepublik kommen aber niemand will
dass menschen sterben und unter diesen
bedingungen dort leben jetzt bleibt noch
träume oder kriminelle herz am richtigen
fleck habe ich verstanden ja und wenn
jemand gesetze über tritt dann tut er
das ja häufig vorsätzlich und man muss
sich an gesetze halten und wenn dann
staaten wie polen darauf dringen das
gesetz eingehalten wird das polnische
gesetz eingehalten wird dann ist das
absolut richtig und nachvollziehbar also
kriminell ich also wenn jemand gesetze
übertritt ich kann jetzt die einzelfälle
nicht einzeln beurteilen wenn jemand
gesetze über tritt dann ist das illegale
und muss verfolgt werden